How you doing? Adam Abbas, you there?
Yes, I'm here. Can you guys hear me?
Yeah. You a Muslim?
Uh, I I'm actually a little unsure, you
know. I don't want I don't want to say I
left Christianity, but I'm desperately
like looking for answers. I know it's
just, you know, Muslims here, but my
interest is in Islam, and I have heard
multiple objections from other Muslim
apologists like Muslim lantern and
stuff, and it's got me questioning all
my Christianity.
Muslim lantern?
Yeah. It's uh I went on his his show and
then I I joined and uh basically the
objections that I have right now like I
I really don't know how to get past and
I'm sure there's like other answers.
That's why I'm, you know, seeking you
guys. I I talked to Sam, it didn't work
out well, but I'm just looking for any
answers.
When you say you talked to Sam, it
didn't work out. But what do you mean?
Like you didn't
He thought I was like undercover. Like
he thought I cuz he saw my last name. He
thought I was like an undercover Muslim,
so he just kicked me, but I never got to
speak with him.
So, what's with the name then? What is
with the name?
That is my last name. I I have a Muslim
father, but my mom's Catholic.
Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Yeah. Listen, listen, brother. I I just
uh I was just telling them I have to go
cuz I have another show to be on at uh
at 8. But I did want to point I do want
to point out notice this is like the uh
this is like what the sixth or so uh
live stream that we did together as a
group uh inviting Muslims to to
challenge us uh and to give us a
reputation of the Islamic dilemma. And
all the guys that post videos and claims
and so on, they don't show up. It's like
they they they like to say stuff when
it's not someone who's going to be able
to take them through what the Quran
says. So anyway, the point was uh in
this discussion that follows, just keep
that in mind that all these guys who say
they can respond to this stuff, they
never show up when we say okay,
open invitation. Anyone who wants to
join us live can can join us live. And
so I just wanted to point out Muslim
lantern. Muslim lantern
um love to have a discussion with you
about the Islamic dilemma. Feel free to
join us anytime. We could Avery, you
could do it here on Avery's channel,
could do it somewhere else. Happy to
have an awesome discussion on the on the
Islamic dilemma. All right, brother.
leaving you in good hands with uh um
GodLogic Giant DLC, but got to cut out.
Thank you. Nice to meet you,
David. Right. So, what what's uh what
were some objections that uh you got hit
with, man, and he cooked you on, man.
So, basically the three days and three
nights prophecy um not being allegedly
not being fulfilled. Uh basically that
you know the stories between the
gospels, they're a little different. And
specifically he said because of the
nights how it has to be uh because of
the prophecy of like Jonah you know in
the belly of the whale has to be three
nights as well and then he read me some
verses in the gospels
and it doesn't uh doesn't match up.
So going off of the three days and three
nights where Jesus says like as Jonah
was three days and three nights in the
belly of the fish so the son of man will
be three days and three nights in the
heart of the earth. And so because Jesus
says it like that, it has to be three
days and three night. It has to be three
nights exactly. Um uh in order for it to
the prophecy to be fulfilled.
Yeah. I mean I'm not like you know
extremely literalist. This is just one
objection that I have heard. But he was
telling me that the Christians they'll
say well you know the Jewish times are a
little bit different um between what
constitutes a day what's a night. But he
said because you know you you know Jesus
threw in three nights specifically
well that has to be you know like was it
was the sun up or was it down like
there's really no getting past
interesting. So uh it's interesting
because when you look at this Jesus
describes the day that he rises from the
dead in many ways. This is actually one
of the ways that he mentions the day
that he rises. Uh talking about a 3-day
time span, 3 days and three nights. He
also says on the third day he will rise.
He also says after 3 days he will rise.
So we see three days and three nights.
On the third day in three days after 3
days all describing a three-day time
span that's all it is, bro. you and and
DLC if you guys have examples of this.
We I know there's examples with Ezra. Um
um if we have some references of that if
you guys want to touch on that, we can.
I'm about to get this verse for you.
Yeah. Um if you check out uh Genesis 42,
Genesis 42 17 to 18. This is where
you'll see like throughout the Hebrew
Bible after and on. This is how the Jews
use the language. So
it says, "And he put them all in custody
for 3 days." Okay. And it says, "On the
third day, he said to them, do this and
you will live for I fear God." Right. So
on the third day, so
what verse is this again? J 42 what?
Genesis 42:17 to 18. Yep.
So on the third day he said this. So but
I thought they were going to be, you
know, they were going to be in custody.
They were going to be in the prison for
3 days, right? But it's on the third day
he says, you know, do this and you will
live. So, it's not like Christians are
just making this up or something or
we're just coming out with nowhere. This
is literally how the Jews use the terms
after and on, third day, 3 days. This is
how it's used throughout the Hebrew
Bible. And Avery mentioned another
example with um um Esther as well.
There's many other examples of this, but
you see verse 18, sorry, verse verse 17.
And he put them in all together in
custody for three days. On the third
day, Joseph said to them, "Do this and
you will live for I fear God." And so
then you know so but so that's on the
third day but were they there all night
or it's on the third day. So on and
after this is yeah it's the same thing.
It's the same thing in my culture the
Arab culture they say oh I stayed for 3
days where he actually meant 2 days and
a half and on the third day he left the
place. It's very common. So you find it
like in Matthew 17 like brother God lo
saying Matthew 17:22 it's very very
specific. The Lord Jesus it's red
letters. So the Lord Jesus said it, the
son of man is going to be delivered into
the hands of men. They will kill him and
on the third day,
right? No, no, no, no. It has to be the
fourth day. Jai,
right? Right.
So if you if you speak to them in that
kind of the way they spoke, oh, they'll
say, "Oh, he stayed for 3 days." But
actually, it was on the third day
something a new thing happened. So they
say, "Oh, he was in there for 3 days."
That's a very like common way of
speaking even even all over the world
even up to this day.
Yeah. And like like in the Talmud for
example, like we were just talking about
the Talmud earlier, it literally says
you like you literally have a quote
there that says a day and a night are
are a portion of time and a portion is
the whole of it. So it's like part of it
is a whole. So this is not again this is
the Talmud. It's not Christians who are
just like making up an apologetic to
kind of like oh this is how we explain
this. This is in the Talmud and it's
saying that a part of the day
and a night they're just a part and a
part is the whole like that's how they
was counted in in the Jewish. So So like
he said like he like so it's funny cuz
he's saying this is what the Christians
are going to tell you but he doesn't
tell you oh it's based on evidence. He
thinks that we're just like making it up
like this is like to explain it away.
No. Yeah. This is why the Muslim lantern
would never debate any I mean he would
never debate. Yeah.
I've been looking for God logic vers
Muslim lantern debate. I haven't seen
it.
If if you if you go on my Patreon, the
video is there, but he deleted it from
his from his uh channel. He really
deleted that stream. But you you and
then when I put it up or a couple of
other Christian brothers and sisters
re-uploaded it, he copyright strike all
of us. So,
um the video you will not be able to
find the video on YouTube because he'll
strike us for putting it up. So, you
have to go to my Patreon um for free and
and you can watch it there.
I definitely will. He's He's a coward,
bro. He's an absolute coward. He'll
never talk to one of us straight up
headto head. The whole entire time I was
trying to talk to him, he's trying to
limit the discussion. Oh, okay. Well,
you only get to ask this this type of
question and really trying to put
parameters on. But everybody before
that, he was speaking freely for no time
limit and all, you know, it's so just a
coward. But this is Esther, brother.
This is Esther chapter 4. This is Esther
chapter 4. Now it talks about how they
were going to fast uh for three days and
three nights um and and Esther was then
going to go to the king see the king
after they fasted. Okay. So like for
example so verse 16 it says
go uh well I'll start 15. Then Esther
told them to reply to Mori. Go gather
all the Jews to be found in Susa and
hold fast on my behalf and do not eat or
drink for three days, night or day.
Right. So, it's three days and three
nights. Right.
Yes.
I and my young women will also fast as
you do. Then I will go to the king,
though it is against the law. And if I
perish, I perish. Mori then went away
and did everything as Esther had ordered
them him. So Esther says, "We're all
going to fast three days and three
nights. And after we fast, when we're
done, I will then go to the king. And if
I die, I die." You know, it is what it
is. Well, we'll see what happens. So,
let's go to the next chapter. Oh, look.
When when is it that she went to the
king? On the third day, Esther put on
her royal robes and stood in the inner
court of the king's palace in front of
the king's quarters while the king was
sitting on his royal throne inside the
throne room opposite the entrance of to
the palace. Wait, hold on a second.
I I thought this was supposed to be
three days and three nights. So, it
should be, you know, on the fourth day
or whatever, right?
No,
it's just an idiom describing a
three-day span. That's all.
And can you put up to um uh 1st Samuel
30 uh 12-13? 1st Samuel 30 12-13. And
this is going to show you again 3 days
and 3 nights and we're going to use
Muslim uh lanterns logic and see if it
follows. So verses 12 uh to 13. Okay.
And they gave him a piece of cake of
figs and two clusters of raisins. And he
had eaten uh sorry. And when he had
eaten, his spirit revived. For they had
not eaten bread or drunk water for three
days and three nights. Okay, three days
and three nights. Remember he made
emphasis. Oh, it says nights. It says
nights. Now watch this. And David said
to him, to whom do you belong?
And where are you from? He said, I'm a
young man of Egypt. Just like, you know,
Muslim land from Egypt. Anyway, servant
to an Amalachite and my master left me
behind because I fell sick 3 days ago.
Whoa. 3 days ago? I thought it was 3
days and three night. I thought, oh, so
3 days ago it's 3 days and three nights.
This is just a figure. It's a way that
they spoke. It's like how they speak.
Yeah, it's a 3 days span.
So 3 days. 3 days and three nights. It's
just a portion of the time is the whole
of the time. Like the whole of the day.
Yeah. Like when you say, "I've been here
all day and it's still in the day."
Yeah. Exactly.
Hasn't finished. The day hasn't
finished, but you say, "I've been here
all day." It's just a way of speaking.
That's definitely sufficient like that.
Uh
yeah, of course. He's not going to tell
you this stuff, you know. He's not
either because he doesn't know this or
he does know it. He's just trying to be
deceptive because he wants you to, you
know, join Islam. But, uh,
he doesn't know, Jack. He's got a script
from all of them. They use the street
dance like for hundreds of years.
I actually saw, not to get off topic, I
saw a Christian guest and he asked the
Muslim Lantern, "Are you aware of what
the strataturin is?" The Muslim Lantern
said he never heard of it.
Yeah.
And, you know, I'm like, okay, how how
are you gonna be like an an apologist?
at least you should know about it. But
um yeah, I mean that that definitely
finishes that argument. Um if you don't
mind,
he's just like objectively a liar. Like
I've heard him talk about topics like,
you know, preservation of the Quran and
different Quric manuscripts. Can you
talk about the SA manuscript for
example? And he just completely lies
about these topics. He just like
objectively lies about these topics. So,
he's not a trustworthy source, but um
I'm glad that you know you came uh to
talk with God Logic and and on here
because this is where you're going to
get the truth and we're going to tell
you this is the full story. We're not
just going to say like, "Oh yeah, this
is the side that we want you to hear.
We're going to tell you everything. Like
if you want to ask us what Muslims say
about this or that, we'll tell you the
best argument that they have and the
best argument against it and you make
the decision." He's only going to tell
you parts of the story and he's going to
lie to you and he's not going to tell
you like, you know, like, oh, Christians
say, you know, night and day just makes
up the whole. But they're just making
that up because, you know, there, you
know, they want to explain away this
contradiction.
When we have tons of evidence, right? We
have tons of evidence that, you know,
100%. And I don't I don't want to stay
too long, but the
Oh, yeah. What's the What's the other
objection?
The um there was like the Passover. Um
when was like Jesus actually crucified?
Um was it like before the Passover or
after the Passover? Um for that I know
there's like a little you know some
people have different perspectives on
what constitutes like the start of the
Passover and the end but data definitely
I'm still wondering about that as well.
Yeah. If you um have you heard of
inspiring philosophy?
Uh no inspiring philosophy? No. Um,
dude, you are, man. You're under a rock.
Inspiring philosophy, bro. He's he's
amazing. He actually has an entire
series dealing with answering all of
these type of questions and objections,
showing the sources, showing scriptures
and stuff like that. Uh, showing
scholarly opinion and commentaries. And
so, and his his videos are short, like,
you know, five minutes or less. You know
what I'm saying? Something maybe seven,
it doesn't matter. But like, they're
they're relatively short. And uh he's
breaking down he's answering all of
these. And so if you if you go on his
channel and this is what it his channel
looks like just really quick. Um
you go there now on my laptop.
Yeah. Inspiring philosophy right here.
This is he has he he does all of the he
just uploaded one today. You know, did
Jesus carry his own cross or did he need
help? You know, supposed Bible.
I heard that one.
Yeah. He does all of these. And um
he has one on that very topic too that
you just mentioned. Um
yeah. Yeah, he does.
It's called when was Jesus crucified?
supposed Bible contradiction number 21.
And yeah, that's
perfect. Yeah, I'm definitely gonna
check this guy out and then I'll watch
the Patreon debate as well. The hidden
debate between you and the boy
that if you can call it that. But yeah,
definitely definitely go ahead and watch
that. Um
subscribe to to Inspiring Philosophy
like binge watch his videos and take
notes. Like don't just watch it to to
watch it. He mentions the references
like as you see in the video is showing
like he's mentioning references. Note it
down. Note it down and so that you know
exactly how to answer these things.
Okay.
Definitely 100%. Just subscribe now. So
thank you very much guys. I appreciate
it.
For sure. For sure.
Life series guys.
Was Was that it? Was that the last one?
There was also another the uh I have to
do like a little research but basically
the story like the woman caught in
adultery. Um, apparently it was like
added in a lot later and that's actually
kind of what like started this whole
thing because that's literally like my
favorite passage. And I just did like a
chat GBT search and it said it's like
not in the earliest manuscripts and that
kind of just took me for a spin.
Yeah,
I don't know if there's like a
there there's there's different opinions
on it. So, um, yeah, it it doesn't show
up in the earliest manuscripts that we
have. And that that's very true. It
doesn't show up in the earliest that we
have. it shows up in the in the later
manuscripts. However, um the view is is
that the view the the view is that it's
still it's a true story, but it was like
early on is trying to find its place in
the writings, right? Like um they're
trying to find its placement there. So,
it's they're saying that it's a true
story of Jesus that was that was that
was narrated. Um, but it's they're
trying to find its place of where it
belongs in the gospel, like where where
it is. So, that's why they're saying
that you don't really see it early on in
the in the earliest manuscripts and the
surviving one, but you do see it in the
in the later ones. Not that it's added
per se, but it shows up in the later
manuscripts. Uh do you guys have
something?
So it's like who did they uh you know
who are they attributing this to as like
the author that was the
right?
Yeah. Not that it's a false story
altogether.
Look um a guy called David Allen Black.
David Allen. Yeah. David Allen. A l an
black
theologian.
Yes. Uh yeah. He he talks about this and
he b you know he'll go into detail and
you can have confidence. uh like in
exactly what Avery just said that this
is definitely a true story and you have
it's in the majority of the manuscripts
right the early ones it's omitted and
sometimes it's in like the end of John
or for example it's like like Avery said
it's like you know in different places
but it's there and he gives you
arguments um if you took up David Ellen
Black um for the um adulterous the one
caught adultery he you'll get a lot of
good information there and um yeah
there's any others as well, but he's
he's a good one.
Thank you very much.
And by the way,
just just to let you know, let's even
grant that this particular story was not
original to the to the gospel. It's not
original to the text, right? Let's say
it's taken out. What changes
with the gospel, with the message, with
the character of Jesus? What changes if
that story is not there?
Nothing.
Nothing. You still have a resurrected
Christ, a crucified Christ, resurrected
Christ. Um the women finding him at the
tomb. Um the uh emergence of the church,
the cowardous apostles turning into bold
preachers. You and and the prophecies of
the crucifixion. You still have all of
this, nothing of the message of of Jesus
and nothing of the theology of God, him
being triune, Jesus being the divine son
of God. Nothing is affected whether this
story is there or not. You know what I'm
saying? So, this will be one of those
variance variants that like it's a it
will be a large it's a large variant.
Like it's a meaningful variant, but it
doesn't affect Christianity at all. Like
it doesn't affect the message of the
gospel in any way, shape, or form. It
doesn't affect the theology of
Christianity in no way, shape, or form.
Bro,
that that's worst case scenario if it
didn't if it really wasn't um a true
story. Like if it if it didn't belong.
Yeah. You hear what I'm saying?
Yes.
So we don't unlike the Muslims Yeah.
Unlike the Muslims, we don't we don't
think that every single word is verbatim
the word of God that he sent down from
heaven and spoke without, you know,
using man to write and and convey the
message. No, we don't believe that. We,
you know, there's human involvement in
the transcription of the scriptures. The
humans write. There's copious errors.
It's uh we're using paper, you know,
papyrus that dies off, you know,
manuscripts don't survive. That happens.
Yet the message of the gospel is still
preserved. That's the that's what the
Christians believe, you know.
And by the way, that's exactly the case
with the Quran as well. But the Muslims
just have a different narrative. But his
but like historically the manuscript
evidence, etc. Like that's exactly the
same case with any written document,
right? So once humans are involved,
you're going to have someone like, you
know, maybe skipping a line or spelling
a word wrong or something like that. Um,
but even if you go to the Muslim
sources, you know, you're talking about
like the woman caught in adultery. This
is like one of the longer, you know, you
could say variants, but guess what? You
have entire chapters that are disputed
in the Islamic corpus. There's uh
there's a scholar by the name of um
Shanthony. Shanthony, you can go to
academia.edu, edu type in Sean Anthony
the lost sers of the Quran the lost sers
of the Quran he talks about two chapters
of the Quran that obey and other
companions had in their Quran that
doesn't exist in today's Quran doesn't
exist at all in today's Quran yeah
doesn't exist at all so
ruins the whole argument for the Quran
then if that's true
yeah exactly Anthony the lost two losers
of the Quran something to that effect
you'll find it with that search and so
that's just to say that this is the case
with any book in history you're going to
have these I mean guess where you don't
have variants when it's like like
Sumerian tablets when we still have the
original stones today because they're
literally written in stone they're cars
right so we don't have like copies of
copies right but anything that's written
down like Avery said papyrus and you
know parchment etc this stuff it it dies
out and you have to rewrite it and then
copy it and someone makes an error here
and then you then guess what you have
for Christians we have the confidence to
know okay we have so much evidence of
the manuscript so now we can know for
sure what exactly Did John write? What
exactly did Matt, you know, inspired by
the Holy Spirit? And we can have amazing
like they're they dispute amongst like
less than 1%. Less than 1% is what
they're disputing. And none of that
changes theology. None of that changes
Christian doctrine or teachings or what
Jesus said or taught. Nothing. Less than
1%. But the Muslims, you have a big big
uh percentage of variance. And it's not
very smart for the Muslim lantern or any
of these Muslims to attack the Bible
because the seventh century when their
Muhammad came the the Bibles that he had
at his time, he's confirming.
Yeah. Yeah. That gets to our topic
today.
So that gets to our topic today. So if
they want to attack um the gospels for
these what they call contradictions,
Muhammad comes to confirm it. We know
that because we we know from manuscripts
exactly what they had in Arabia at that
time. We know what they had before that
time, before Muhammad and after. And and
it's exactly what we have today,
right? So if
shooting on the foot,
if they want to attack it, they said
Allah just confirmed something wrong,
right?
It's stupidity.
Yeah. And then that's like the that's
like the right approach when you're
talking to a soul there. And like, oh,
you know, there's a contradiction in
three days and three nights. Like, oh,
is that the same Bible that Muhammad
said he confirmed?
Yes.
So, it's like it's like that's that's
another way you can deal with that when
you're talking. atheist can say that
maybe but not a Muslim because otherwise
you have to keep Islam then if you're
going to take that position.
Thank you very much. Um yeah, that's
everything I'll definitely be studying.
Um, do you have like any anything quick
or even like a video I could check out
just uh like I know there's plenty of
answers for John 17:3 that are pro the
Trinity still like it's not just a you
know this ruins the Trinity, but for me
like I I don't have a an adequate
response yet to John 17:3, but if you
guys could kind of like point me in that
direction and that'll be the the last
thing and I appreciate it very much. I
mean, Avery's got tons and tons of like
debates where that those come up.
Uh, so you can you can certainly like
search the channel and you'll find that,
but um I mean we could just quickly go
over it with you if you want like but
our archive has a uh
Oh, archive got it. Yeah,
archive has a video and so here's a
here's a video from an archives channel
where Sam Shimone explains it. It's
about 10 minutes long and uh it's it's
funny because at the end of this uh the
Muslim accepts Christ Jesus. So, um, uh,
so yeah. So, we got, uh, let me just put
it right here. I'mma share it with you.
So, I'mma put it right here in the in
the, uh, chat on YouTube. And then also,
I'm putting it right here in the private
chat on StreamYard. Do you see the
private chat? Oh, I lost him. He
probably accidentally clicked uh clicked
another tab.
Oh, yeah. There he goes. Yo, can you
hear Can you hear us, Adam? Can you hear
us? Adam,
can you hear us? Hello? Can he even see
us? I think he's he's actually frozen.
All right.
Yeah, it looks like he's walking around.
Maybe the Wi-Fi got um messed up.
Wi-Fi done got him, man.
Yeah, man. But yeah, guys. Um let let
that be just be a lesson really quick.
Stop going on the Oh, there you go. Stop
going on these panels when you're not
ready, guys. Can you hear us?
Yes. Yes, I can hear you. Sorry, I got a
phone call. I'm on do not disturb app.
All right, so I I put the uh the you the
link of the video, John 173. Sam
explaining it. I put it in the
StreamYard private chat. Do you see
that?
Um, I see only one uh comment from
Scales. I think I joined in a little
late. If you don't mind just resending
it, I'll screenshot it.
Yeah, I I'll put it back down in the
regular YouTube chat and then I'mma put
it in the private area. So,
try to copy that. Save that. I just put
in the in the StreamYard chat, too.
Thank you.
Yeah. Check that out. Take notes, absorb
it, learn it, and you'll be good to go.
Thank you very much, SCI. Thank you
guys, Jay. Thank you, David. I
appreciate you. God bless.
God bless, bro.
Yeah. We hope that you uh do some
research on what we said and come come
back. Come back home. Come back home to
Jesus.
Absolutely. Thank you, guys.
If you're not prepared, you should not
be joining
um opposing people's platforms. Okay? if
you're not prepared and you you know
when you're not prepared. I I really
don't I really don't understand it. I
don't I don't get it when people do it.
Um but you you shouldn't you should not
do that, man. Cuz again, the devil is
out there to deceive you and that's all
they want to just cast doubt. And notice
how when you come here, these things are
easily answerable, right? Easily
answerable. Um so, uh use wisdom, man.
Use wisdom uh with these social media.
you're on social media, uh, you know,
you're on Tik Tok and and YouTube, these
platforms come out and they're
challenging Christianity and you want to
probably give an answer, give a defense,
move in wisdom. If you're not ready for
that, if that's not what you do, don't
do that. Okay? You don't have to go up
there. All right? So,